HERE TO HELP US UNDERSTAND
THE COMPLEXITIES OF THIS ISSUES
ARE NEW NIGHTLY SHOW SPECIAL
COMMENTATOR SUSIE ESSMAN.
>> WELCOME, SUZE.
>> THANKS, LARRY.
>> Larry:.
I HAVE GOT ONE MAJOR PROBLEM
WITH THIS NEW LIBIDO DRUG.
WHY WOULD A WOMAN OF MY AGE IN
GOD'S NAME WOULD I WANT MY
LIBIDO BACK?  EVERY DUMB THING I
EVER DID IN MY YOUTH WAS BECAUSE
I WAS LISTENING TO THE DERANGED
LITTLE VOICE IN MY HEAD TELLING
ME I NEEDED TO GET LAID.
EVERY HANGOVER, EVERY FAKE
ORGASM, EVERY TIME I BROKE INTO
BILL PULLMAN'S HOUSE SO I COULD
HIDE IN HIS CLOSET WHILE HE
SLEPT --
>> AND THIS WAS THE NINETIES, SO
JUST TO BE CLEAR, ONE THING I
DON'T NEED IS MY COOTER DOING
JEDI MIND TRICKS ON ME LIKE
OBI-VAJ KENOBI.
>> Larry: UHM, YOU JUST SAID
OBI-VAJ KENOBI, RIGHT?
>> YES, I DID.
>> Larry: OKAY.
I JUST WANTED TO BE CLEAR.
I JUST WANTED TO BE CHEER.
NOW THERE ARE WOMEN WHO HAVE LOW
LIBIDO AND MISS HAVING SEX.
THAT IS DEFINITELY A THING.
>> MAYBE.
CHECK OUT THIS QUOTE FROM A
WOMAN IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES",
NO LESS.
REPLACING THE DREAD I HAVE FOR
INTIMACY WITH DESIRE WOULD BE
LIFE CHANGING.
>> I WOULD THINK SO.
ALL I AM SAYING IS IF YOU ARE
LITERALLY DREADING INTIMACY
MAYBE THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE
GOING ON.
THE THING THAT GETS ME IS THIS
ASSUMPTION JUST BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO HAVE SEX YOU HAVE
A MENTAL DISORDER.
HEY, FELLOWS, MAYBE YOUR WIFE IS
NOT CRAZY.
MAYBE SHE JUST DOESN'T WANT TO
(BLEEP) YOU.
>> Larry: GOOD POINT.
>> I AM JUST SAYING.
>> HAVE YOU TRIED HITTING THE
GYM?  BUYING HER FLOWERS?
HAVING SEX THAT IS NOT JUST 45
SECONDS OF JACKHAMMERING
FOLLOWED BY A SWEATY APOLOGY?
THE FDA REJECTED THIS THING
TWICE BEFORE AND THEY MIGHT HAVE
BEEN RIGHT.
LISTEN TO THESE SIDE EFFECTS.
>> THIS IS A DRUG YOU TAKE EVERY
DAY AND THEN GO OUT AND HAVE
YOUR DAILY ROUTINE.
SO IF YOU PASS OUT WHILE DRIVING
A CAR, IF YOU PASS OUT WHILE YOU
ARE TAKING YOUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
AND HIT YOUR HEAD I MEAN THIS
CAN BE SERIOUS AND UNEXPECTED.
>> A SEX PILL THAT MIGHT MAKE
YOU PASS OUT?
>> WHICH DOCTOR IS ENDORSING
THIS BESIDES DR. HUXTABLE?
>> Larry: WOW.
SOLID COSBY BURN.
THAT'S RIGHT, (BLEEP).
EVEN OUR COMMENTARIES HAVEN'T
FORGOTTEN ABOUT YOU.
>> YOU BETCHA AND FINALLY
I JUST WANT TO SAY, I KNOW
PEOPLE THINK THIS IS A FEMINIST
ISSUE, LIKE YOU SAID, LARRY, SEX
PILLS HAVE BEEN OUT THERE FOR
MEN. MEN HAVE 26 AND WOMEN
HAVE ZERO WHICH IS ALSO MOST
COUPLE'S ORGASM RATIO.
ONE OF THE GROUPS FIGHTING FOR
APPROVAL, FDA APPROVAL OF THIS
WONDER DRUG IS CALLED EVEN THE
SCORE.
ALL RIGHT.
THEY HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
FRAMING THIS IN TERMS OF ORGASM
EQUALITY.
BUT BECAUSE I HAD FREE TIME ON
MY HANDS BECAUSE OF ALL THE
NON-BANGING I DO I FOUND OUT
THAT EVEN THE SCORE IS JUST A PR
CAMPAIGN FUNDED BY THE DRUG
COMPANY THAT MAKES THIS PILL!
IT IS LIKE IF YOUR METH DEALER
TRIES TO TELL YOU YOU NEEDED TO
BUY HIS METH BECAUSE YOU
SUFFERED FROM HAVING TOO MANY
TEETH.
>> THE WHOLE THING IS JUST SPIN.
>> Larry: THAT IS FASCINATING.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THIS WAS ABOUT
WIN FOR SCIENCE OR FEMINISM BUT
JUST FOR BRANDING?
>> AND FOR WOMEN WHO LOVE TO
FALL ASLEEP WHILE THEY ARE
DRIVING.
>> Larry: OH.
THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> LOOK, MAYBE THERE IS A GREAT
FEMALE SEX PILL OUT THERE, BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS IT.
AND BESIDES, I DON'T WANT A PILL
THAT INCREASES DESIRE.
I WANT A PILL THAT INCREASES
SATISFACTION.
>> Larry: THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> OKAY?
>> I MEAN, HELLO.
>> Larry: THAT MAKES SENSE.
>> FOR ONCE I COULD BE THE ONE
ORGASMING AFTER 45 SECONDS AND
FALL ASLEEP AND THEN HE COULD BE
THE ONE POKING ME BECAUSE I
AM SNORING SO LOUD.
>> Larry: SUSIE
ESSMAN, EVERYONE!